thank you very much for joining us i'm
john langler we should point out we are
expecting a special report from cbs news
at any moment this afternoon
from washington d.c president joe biden
is issuing more
executive orders to push forward his
agenda on the coronavirus
he signed two more today bringing the
total to now 29
in just his first 48 hours on the job
these executive orders will increase
access to food for the needy
they allow workers to turn down jobs
that may risk their health without
losing their unemployment benefits
also included in these benefits clearing
the path to a 15
an hour minimum wage for federal workers
president biden also signed
10 executive orders yesterday all part
of his covet 19 response plan
so while the president can sign
executive orders on his own
his 1.9 trillion dollar relief package
does need congressional approval
the plan aims to stabilize the economy
and shore up vaccine distribution among
other things
some conservative lawmakers are balking
at the price tag just last month they
approved a nearly trillion dollar
measure
this weekend the white house will meet
with a bipartisan group of senators to
try and craft a compromise
house democrats are working to draft
their own legislation that they can pass
as soon as next month